[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une émotion pour moi c'est le tout début
de la soirée le prendre le bout de bois
j'ai dit ça tout ça ça va faire un
pinceau
où
c'est vrai que c'est du rêve les gens
ont envie de réaliser de travailler avec
leurs mains et de voir un petit peu ce
qu'ils peuvent réaliser
c'est une rencontre avec le papier peint
à la planche qui a fait que j'ai eu
envie de mener cette expérience de
monter cet atelier derrière cette façade
d'une arrière-cour deux tours tout un
monde imaginaire celui coloré et
onirique qui habille nos murs du coup si
mon cv à voir en voiture noire à
l'atelier dhofar ont créé des papiers
peints d'exception et on recrée ceux qui
ont disparu
ça c'est un document de 10 781 à peu
près
donc on va leur constituent
intégralement on a déjà reconstitué le
papier pas en lui-même est là maintenant
à faire la frise il y a vingt ans que
françois xavier richard a créé l'atelier
sans être du milieu un pari fou pour le
jeune homme qui s'est plongée dans
l'étude de techniques ancestrales
ici on n'utilise pas d'encre mais une
matière très spéciale pour retrouver le
grain des couleurs d'autrefois
on va sur les techniques de l'époque
proche du xviiie l'origine même de
l'impunité et donc c'est des pigments
naturellement vicieux d'oxydation de
métal pour la plupart et puis de
minéraux donc des offres des terres des
choses c'est cette peinture d'un noir
profond qui va être apposée selon des
gestes ancestraux sur ce papier de 120 g
d'épaisseur ça peut paraître assez assez
rudimentaire comme technique mais on est
d'une précision redoutable
[Musique]
le prennent de l'artisanat d'art si je
puis dire c'est le trail avec le temps
c'est de ce lot mais c'est le côté on
peut pas aller plus vite que la musique
il ya l'apprentissage qui se fait
beaucoup par la pratique c'est pas juste
de la théorie et du coup c'est là il
fallait montrer avec ce qu'on était
capable de faire qu'on pouvait prétendre
être ce qu'on appelle un artisan d'art
ponts
un pied dans le passé l'autre dans la
modernité
les formes en bois ont été remplacées
par une matière en résine et la presse
en bois également par un système
ultramoderne reste la superposition des
impressions parfois plus d'une vingtaine
pour un seul papier
je n'attends pas de médoc mans le
tamponnais je sais c'est très important
je viens placer ma planche sur le papier
je presse une fois voilà je recommence
aux impressions différents seront
nécessaires pour ce papier destiné au
musée de philadelphie
chaque réalisation est unique pour des
destinations aux quatre coins du monde
palais châteaux demeures prestigieuses
rien n'est trop beau on a ici la
pharmacie sans tabac est mauvais la c1
au petit chouchou celui là c'est un
super projet ça c'était l'hôtel jacobsen
un des plus anciens documents de papier
peint qu'on est ici 1781 à peu près et
ça c'est vraiment à l'image du papier
peint naïve décalé bizarre françois
xavier richard imagine aussi ses propres
décors abolissant les frontières entre
l'artisanat l'art et le design
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup d'artisans
d'art qui qui brouillent ses frontières
et qui ont la capacité ajustements
gommer ses frontières qui en fait pour
moi cet instant et sont des frontières
qui sont un peu franco française
elles sont pas que franco française mais
on n'a pas les mêmes phénomènes par
exemple au japon vous aider
unis ou être un artiste c'est pas être
un artiste dans un secteur bien précis
on n'a pas de pedigree à montrer avant
de pouvoir être considéré comme un
artiste
enfin
[Musique]
nous remontons le temps pour nous
plonger dans les années d'avant guerre
celle de l'insouciance et des échappées
belles
ces années où les automobiles étaient
encore fabriquée à la main comme ici
chez auto classique touraine
tous les véhicules d'avant guerre avait
une ossature en bois ce qui permettait
de
de pouvoir fixer la tôle voilà donc sur
ces véhicules principalement s'il n'y
avait que la caisse la caisse
l'habitacle qui était en bois et après
tout ce qui est elle n'avait pas de
structure bois ni la partie avant capot
et l avant il n'y avait pas de structure
bois
[Musique]
j'ai une formation de menuisier ébéniste
à mai avec un brevet professionnel un
brevet de maîtrise j'avais gg
on m'a appris à dessiner des escaliers
en colimaçon donc qui est qu'ils ont la
même technique que ces voitures là et
j'ai transposé la menuiserie à la
l'automobile chaque pièce mécanique airs
façonnés à la main un savoir qui ne
s'apprend plus dans les écoles
[Musique]
je vais pas réussir à faire quelque
chose que j'ai vu que je ne connais pas
faut vraiment à un ancien va nous
permettre qui a déjà travaillé dessus
vous guider sur certaines choses
ce que tous les réglages se font à
l'oreille et au régime moteur et c'est
un ressenti puisque une queue comme
manière de travailler
[Musique]
l'atelier réparer recrée les plus
prestigieuses voitures d'avant-guerre
comme cette mythique l'ancien astur à
2938 pour la plus grande fierté du
patron patrick delage arrière petit fils
du fondateur de la marque
il n'y a pas d'école qui forment
maintenant et tôlier formeur le
compagnonnage même et les compagnons du
devoir former des tôlier formeur de
moins en moins et donc aujourd'hui on
est confronté à prendre des apprentis à
les former nous mêmes c'est de plus en
plus on arrive à ça et ça marche très
bien
ces voitures là étant donné qu'elle y
avait dû y avait du bois il y avait du
cuir il y avait des matières nobles
on a on a sept
ouais cette sensation de pouvoir
transmettre une époque à une génération
qui arrive sur sur les métiers
maximilien et la dernière recrue de
l'atelier c'est des métiers qui sont
faut être très méticuleux c'est des
métiers où c'est long on voit ça va
faire un peu plus de trois ans que je
suis ici et vous voyez la lancia qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure à sort tout juste pas
ça a été trois ans de trois ans de
travail
donc ya pas enfin c'est toute une équipe
qui travaille dessus mais bon enfin
dessus moi j'ai peut-être passage pas
peut-être plus de 1000 ou 1500 heures
donc c'est vrai qu'il faut vraiment être
vraiment aimé ce qu'on fait quoi aimer
le travail pour pour aller jusqu'au bout
quoi il pas abandonné
alors alexandre le bas sont là c'est un
basson nous bonnet d'âne sortir de ton
atelier il est tout neuf il n'a jamais
été jouée donc le bois n'a jamais vibré
c'est les premiers sons
[Musique]
musicien joue avec son corps dont il
faut que l'instrument soit à l'image de
son corps donc façonne un peu mais là
sur ce sur cet outil il peut travailler
le musicien moi en l'occurrence c'est
lui c'est mystérieux un peu derrière
selon qu'ils sont tout de suite qu'un
beau son lorsque quelque chose un peu
plus rêche saint mystère
[Musique]
c'est comme si en fait la personne
d'olivier était empreinte dans le bois
c'est curieux c'est curieux ça il y à 40
ans qu'olivier côté conçoit des hautbois
et débats son honneur de l'eure-et-loir
des instruments nouveaux et d'autres
reconstitué à partir d'originaux
fabriquer du 15e au 17e siècle
je voulais voir comment était fabriquée
les instruments à l'époque à quoi il
ressemblait et j'avais vu jamais mesuré
j'ai des copines et puis c'est parti
comme ça c'était sans fin
notre homme a même réinventer certains
instruments en s'appuyant sur des
dessins du moyen-âge ou de la
renaissance de longues années lui hand
était nécessaire pour dénicher des bois
durs dont certains auront séché plus de
15 ans j'ai donc ici plusieurs bois la
série du bruit une belle section de
bruit pour les hautbois baroque au
classique ça sérieux et ben pour le les
aubois modern haye et ben ça c'est le
bruit et enfin le pôle et basson
l'érable on parle de ces bois là
non là on fabrique la petite broche d'un
basson barreaux c'est la paire
intérieure qui tourne la main les oies
il tranche le bois quoi c'est le débute
le basson là où c'est le plus important
pas critique man 2 avec le bocal on
mélange donc maintenant il faut façonner
cette percée c'est alizé donc la paire
c'est fait
il faut maintenant veut tourner et
raboté
[Musique]
elle est passée par dessus tout cas
démenti aujourd'hui le m s'attache à
transmettre ces savoirs en fait on
s'inscrit dans une dans une culture dans
une tradition de savoir faire de gestes
qu'il faut apprendre est qu'il faut
pratiquer
chaque mois olivier côté se rend à la
sorbonne pour les répétitions du
sorbonne scholars un ensemble formé par
des passionnés de musique renaissance et
baroque
plusieurs instruments sortent de son
atelier
[Musique]
c'est un instrument qui n'existe nulle
part ailleurs que fabriqués par olivier
côté et quelques autres facteurs non
mais très pur je dirais non parce qu'ils
n'avaient que des copains et copines
ce sont des luxes et que mon come back
qui nous tient
les amis quoi alors jouer de la musique
ensemble vinci du basson anciens et sans
doute moder aussi et que c'est un
merveilleux amis et musiciens
recréer l'atmosphère des fêtes de la
renaissance évoqué les décors muraux
d'autrefois our faire vrombir les
voitures d'avant-guerre autant de savoir
perpétuer et conservé pour continuer à
faire vivre notre patrimoine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]